-Donald Trump made an appearance
on Fox News last night,
and he was very normal
and coherent
and made lots of lucid,
intelligent comments and...
Sorry.
It just seems a little weird.
Are you sure that card
is right, Wally?
-Sorry, Seth.
I just hired a new guy.
Let me make sure
there aren't any mistakes.
-Okay.
Should just be a second,
everybody.
[ Pen scribbling ]
-Oh. That's spelled wrong.
That too.
Oh, boy, he messed that part up
really bad.
I don't even know
what he was trying to do there.
Okay, just the one final change,
and we're good.
Okay, Seth. All set.
-Alright. Okay, great.
Here we go.
Donald Trump went
on Fox News last night
and lost his [bleep] mind.
Alright. Thanks, Wally.
[ Laughter ]
-No worries, boss.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, who is, uh...
Who is this new guy, by the way?
-Eh, just some kid I met on one
of those QAnon message boards.
You'd like him.
-Oh, I bet I would.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Okay, so, you know
how Donald Trump is still,
as of this moment, the leader
of the Republican Party
and front-runner for the party's
presidential nomination in 2024?
And you know how he's also
what constitutional scholars
technically refer to
as a, quote,
"ass-load of legal trouble"?
Well, yesterday
he went on Fox News
to talk about all of it.
And as is par for the course
for Trump, despite being
sort of softball question
after softball question,
he fully disintegrated
into a sweaty,
red-faced, rambling,
incoherent mess.
It's amazing that Trump
continues to have the confidence
of a man
who is ready for anything
while being prepared
for nothing.
[ Laughter ]
If Trump was on "Family Feud,"
he would buzz in before
he got asked a question.
"Top five answers on the board."
[ Bell dings ]
[ As Trump ]
"Hunter Biden's laptop."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
"Well, the question was gonna be
best places for a first date,
so I don't think
it's gonna be up there."
[ As Trump ]
"Well, it's got to be somewhere.
We might as well look there."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Now, we all know
that whenever he goes
on Fox News
or does a rally or speaks
in public in any way,
Trump is gonna say
a bunch of crazy [bleep]
But that's especially
problematic right now
because he's facing multiple,
very serious criminal
investigations and civil suits
and what he says can be used
against him in court.
There are multiple grand juries
looking into his attempts
to overturn the 2020 election.
There's the Justice
Department's investigation
of all the classified documents
he stole from the White House.
And there's the lawsuit
New York Attorney General
Letitia James
announced yesterday,
seeking to bar him
from doing business in the state
after what she called years
of staggering fraud.
-The New York state
attorney general suing
former President Trump,
three of his adult children,
and the Trump Organization
for $250 million,
accusing the Trump family
of, quote,
"staggering fraud"
in a sweeping civil suit
and looking to ban them from
doing business in New York.
-We show that they violated
several state criminal laws,
including falsifying
business records,
issuing false
financial statements,
insurance fraud,
and engaging in a conspiracy
to commit each of these
state law violations.
We believe the conduct
alleged in this action
also violates
federal criminal law,
including issuing
false statements
to financial institutions,
and bank fraud.
-At this point, it would just
be easier to list the crimes
Trump hasn't committed.
I mean, as far as we know,
he hasn't broken
any maritime laws.
Although we say that now,
and then like in a week,
audio will surface of Trump
trying to bribe a seal to prove
the election was stolen.
[ As Trump ]
Bark bark, clap clap, bark,
Dominion voting machines --
excuse me! -- clap, bark.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] He also
probably hasn't jaywalked,
but only because jaywalking
happens in a straight line
and Trump only goes
around in circles.
[ Laughter ]
It's also very funny that James
is suing Trump for $250 million,
an amount he would definitely
never be able to pay.
If the suit succeeds,
we're gonna see
an "everything must go" sign
on Trump Tower.
It would be
the tackiest fire sale ever.
You'd just see a bunch
of New Yorkers
walking down Fifth Avenue
lugging giant chandeliers
or marble water fountains
or a golden toilet.
"Can you believe it?
I got this for 20 bucks.
If the Yankees
win the World Series,
I'm gonna get wasted
and puke in this thing!"
[ Laughter ]
"I'm gonna puke like a king."
And then there's
the DOJ investigation
of the classified documents.
Yesterday, we told you that
the independent arbiter
who had been appointed to sift
through the material seized
in the FBI search of Mar-a-Lago
had chastised
the Trump legal team
for not providing any proof
that Trump had declassified
any of the documents.
And sure enough, yesterday,
an appeals court intervened
to reverse a lower court ruling
and allow the DOJ investigation
to continue.
The appeals court judges
ruled that
the DOJ could move forward
with its criminal investigation
because there's no reason
to believe
Trump declassified the documents
or that he should get
to keep them even if he did.
-Just a short time ago,
the 11th Circuit
Court of Appeals
handed Trump's lawyers
a huge defeat.
Three appeals court judges,
two of them appointed
by Trump himself,
lifted a judge's order
that prevented
the Justice Department
from using classified documents
that were seized from Mar-a-Lago
in its criminal investigation.
-An appeals court has ruled
that the Justice Department
can have access to roughly 100
highly sensitive
classified documents
that were taken from Mar-a-Lago.
Trump has been arguing
that all the documents
seized from his club
are his personal property
and that if the FBI found
anything classified in there,
well, Trump magically
declassified it
when he was president,
even though he has no record
of ever having done that.
The judges write, quote,
"The declassification argument
is a red herring
because declassifying
an official document
would not change its content
or render it personal.
So even if we assumed
that Plaintiff, Trump,
did declassify some
or all of these documents,
that would not explain why he
has a personal interest in them.
-Exactly.
Claiming you declassified them,
on top of being a lie,
is also irrelevant.
You don't get to keep them.
Trump thinks declassifying
something is like calling dibs.
Watch out if you're ever
at a big group dinner with him.
[ As Trump ]
I'm officially declassifying
those jalapeno poppers.
[ Laughter ]
So hands off the poppers.
But also, before
I declassify the poppers,
we ordered the poppers
as a group,
so we'll still be splitting
the check for the poppers.
You pay for my pop.
[ Laughter ]
You pay, my pop.
[ Normal voice ]
So, that's what was happening
as Trump sat down
with his best friend
slash only friend,
Sean Hannity.
And as is usual --
as is usually the case
with these interviews,
Hannity desperately tried
to help Trump out
by teeing him up
with softball questions
designed to defend Trump,
but accidentally ended up giving
Trump free rein to go totally
off script and screw himself.
For example,
as we mentioned earlier,
Trump and his lawyers have been
arguing that he declassified
the documents
he stole from the White House.
So far, they have refused
to provide any details
or evidence as to how
and when exactly that happened.
And now we know why --
there are none.
Trump told Hannity
he thinks you can declassify
a top secret document by simply
declaring it declassified
inside your own head.
-You had said on Truth Social
a number of times
you did declassify.
-I did declassify. Yes.
-Okay.
Well, is there a process?
What was your process
to declassify?
-There doesn't have to be
a process, as I understand it.
You know, there's different --
people say different things,
but as I understand it,
there doesn't have to be...
If you're the president
of the United States,
you can declassify just
by saying it's declassified,
even by thinking about it.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think the whole time
Trump was answering,
Hannity was thinking,
"Why the [bleep] did I ask him
what his process was?
Ohh, what the [bleep]
is wrong with me?!
Oh, today's the day
he's gonna have a process.
Get your head out of your ass,
Hannity!"
[ Laughter ]
Trump's argument
is that you can just
declassify things in your mind.
It's officially declassified
as long as you believe
it's declassified.
That's according to Trump's
newest legal adviser,
Tinkerbell.
Oh, and heads up...
Heads up, Tink --
he's not gonna pay you.
So, Trump says you can
declassify something
just by thinking about it.
Although even that
is a shaky defense
because it requires
establishing that Trump
is capable of thinking
about things.
I mean, even if it were true
that the law said you could
declassify something
just by thinking about it,
all a judge would have to do
is look into Trump's eyes
and immediately rule
that there's just nothing
going on in there.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at that.
Does that look more like a man
who is declassifying
top secret documents
or an emu who just found
the zoo camera?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Whenever he's on TV,
Trump has this energy.
-It's amazing to me --
Emmanuel, don't do it.
Emmanuel.
I'm trying to tell them
thank you.
Buddy, I'm trying to tell them
Don't do it. Don't.
Emmanuel.
Emmanuel. Emmanuel.
Emmanuel...
-Interestingly, Emmanuel
also stole a bunch
of classified documents.
[ Laughter ]
There was also
this part of the clip
that I thought
was very revealing
and probably drove
Trump's lawyers insane.
-Is there a process?
What was your process
to declassify?
-There doesn't have to be
a process, as I understand it.
You know, there's different --
people say different things,
but as I understand it,
there doesn't have to be...
There doesn't have to be
a process.
There can be a process,
but there doesn't have to be.
-What do you mean there doesn't
have to be a process?
If Trump had been one of
the framers of the Constitution,
every article would have
ended with "or not!"
[ Laughter ]
Of course, there is a process.
It's government.
There's a process
for everything.
Nothing happens by magic.
You can't just change
your address
or file your taxes
by thinking about it.
Although based on Letitia James'
press conference,
that's what Trump will probably
use as his next excuse.
[ As Trump ] I may have inflated
my assets on legal bank forms,
but in my head I was honest
down to the last penny.
[ Normal voice ] But by far the
craziest part of the interview
came when Trump fully unraveled
and seemed to suggest
that the FBI was maybe
searching Mar-a-Lago
to look for
Hillary Clinton's emails.
It made so little sense,
even Hannity
had to jump in and stop him.
-There's also a lot
of speculation
because of what they did,
the severity of the FBI coming
and raiding Mar-a-Lago --
were they looking for
the Hillary Clinton emails
that were deleted,
but they are around someplace.
Were they looking for the --
spying on Trump's --
-Wait, you're not saying
you had it, did...?
-No, no.
They may be saying...
They may have thought
that it was in there.
-Wait, what? The...
[ Laughter ]
The FBI searched
your private resort
to look for
Hillary Clinton's emails?
The ones you supposedly
been looking for forever.
That made so little sense,
even Hannity had to jump in
and say...
-Don't do it.
[ Laughter ]
-But, man, what a twist --
It would be...
What a twist it would be
if Trump accidentally admitted
that he's the one
who stole all of Hillary
Clinton's missing emails.
I mean, honestly,
that would be worth it.
Even M. Night Shyamalan
would have been like,
"[Bleep] Hats off. I mean..."
[ As Trump ]
A lot of people are saying
maybe the FBI was looking
for Hillary's emails
because maybe they were in there
because maybe in 2015
I sat down at a computer
and broke into a server
and stole them,
because in reality,
despite representing
as a very dumb man,
I'm actually a computer genius.
A hacker!
[ Laughter ]
That's what we call ourselves.
We love the hackers, don't we?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] This guy
is still, as of this moment,
the leader of
the Republican Party
and the front-runner for their
presidential nomination in 2024.
There are pro-Trump candidates
up and down the ballot
across the country,
and this is what
they're standing behind.
The guy is so corrupt
that at this point
he can commit crimes just...
-By thinking about it.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The midterm elections
are coming up.
So to make sure that you're good
to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at headcount.org
to check your voter
registration status
or to register to vote.